نستكمل نستكمل معكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه
التي نخصصها للاوضاع الجاريه في السودان
والقتال الدائر هناك حيث اعلن كل من قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني على
موافقتهما على مقترح الامم المتحده بفتح
مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه هذا واكد
الجيش خلال بيان ان فتح المسارات سيكون
لمده ثلاث ساعات وان ذلك لا يلغي حقها في
الرد عند حدوث اي تجاوزات من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع من جهتها قالت قوات الدعم
السريع انها ستسمح بمرور الحالات
الانسانيه لمده اربع ساعات كما انها
ستحتفظ بحق الرد على اي اعتداء من عناصر
القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
هذا واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اجرت اتصالا هاتفيا
مع رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان كما اجرت اتصالا اخر مع نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده محمد حمدان دقلو واكد وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه ضروره التهدئه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على
مقدرات السودان كما شدد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على اهميه العوده الى الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي يضمن تحقيق الامن للسودان
الصوت بيجلس الداير حوالين كل
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من مدينه مروي مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار ما هي اخر
التطورات والتحديثات على الارض لو سمحت
اخر المعلومات ما اكدته لنا مصادر عسكريه
عليمه بان الجيش السوداني او قوات المسلحه
السودانيه بسطت سيطرتها بالكامل على مطار
مروي الدولي وعلى قاعده مروي العسكريه
السودانيه الجيش السوداني نؤكد بانه بسط
سيطرته كامله على مطار مروي الدولي وعلى
قاعده مروي العمليه الجويه المصادر ايضا
اكدت بان العمليه العسكريه التي تمت خلال
الساعات الماضيه اسفل عنها اشتباكات عنيفه
هذه الاشتباكات اضطرت معها حسب المعلومات
قوات الدعم السريع
لمغادره القاعده ولمغادره المطار يبدو ان
قوات سودانيه افسحت المجال او اعطت مهله
لهذه القوات ولكن اشتدت عمليه الحصار داخل
هذه القاعده عليه فان قوات الدعم السريعه
الان هي خارج حدود مطار مروي الدولي ايضا
المعلومات التي بحوزتنا الان بان قوات
الدعم السريع عندما غادرت هذه
القاعده والمطار اصطحبت معها نحو 27 من
افراد القوه المصريه التي تتبع للجيش
المصري وتتبع للقوات الجويه السودانيه اي
هذا يعني ان القوه المصريه التابعه للجيش
السوداني هي الان خارج القاعده ولكنها
بمعيه قوات الدعم السريعه ايضا المعلومات
تؤكد بان الجيش السوداني او القوات
المسلحه السودانيه استطاعت ان تستحوذ على
السيارات واليات من داخل المطار التابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع وايضا تمكنت من الحصول
على سياره تعرف بسياره السيطره
تستخدم للتنسيق وللاتصالات وقد اديرت بها
العمليه العسكريه كما ان نحو 47 الى 50
فرد من افراد قوات الدعم السريع هم الان
يوصفون كاسرى بحصبه توصيف العسكري
بيد القوات المسلحه السودانيه هنا في
مدينه مروي هذه ابرز التحديثات وابرز
المعلومات التي يمكن ان تصدر من مروي
لتعطي اشارات جديده حول مسار هذه العمليه
العسكريه التي بدات يوم الامس في مروي
يعني النزار منذ بدايه هذا الصراع كانت
الانظار تتجه على ثلاث مطارات وهي يعني
تركز حول الصراع منذ بدايه الصراع بين
الطرفين مطار الخرطوم مطار مروي التي
تحدثت عنه في شمال السودان والابيض في
ولايه شمال كردفان في غربي البلاد اليوم
اذا اردنا يعني ايجاز الوضع الامني لهؤلاء
لهذه المطارات الثلاث كيف يمكن الحديث
عنها
مطار الخرطوم بحكم وضعيته هو مطار متاخم
للقياده العامه للجيش بالتالي طبيعه
التعامل العسكريه قد يختلف من التعامل في
مطارات كمطار الابيض مطار الابيض ايضا هو
من المطارات الارتكازيه والاستراتيجيه وهو
ايضا بمثابه قاعده عسكريه تنطلق منه
القوات الجويه السودانيه
وجود القوات وكثافه القوات والتمركز
القوات وعدد القوات المحيطه بهذه المواقع
هو ما سيعطي مؤشر حول طبيعه العمليه كيف
ستمضي والى اي حد تتجه غلبه الانتصار
والهزيمه في مثل هذه المعارك اما هنا في
فان هذا المطار
يقع في منطقه مائيه في شمال السودان يحاذي
مدينه هي مدينه مروي مطار وفي يلحق به
قاعده عسكريه هذا المطار هو له خصوصيه
القوات الجويه هي كانت متمركزه الطيران
العسكري لم في هذه العمليه هذه ايضا واحده
من الاشارات واحده من الملاحظات المهمه
بان العمليه العسكريه التي حسمت قبل قليل
هنا في مطار مروي لم يستخدم فيها الطيران
العسكري ربما في المطارين الاخيرين سواء
كان في الخرطوم او في مروي قد يشارك تشارك
القوات الجويه قد تشارك القوات البريه لكن
هنا في مروي العمليه تمت عبر قوات بريه
عبر مدفعيه عبر اشتباكات داخل هذا المطر
هذه هي الوضعيه وهذه هي الطبيعه
الاشتباكات وطبيعه العمليه العسكريه التي
سواء تمت هنا في مطار مروي او في مطار
الخرطوم الذي ايضا يحمل خصوصيه لانه يحاذي
تقع عسكريه يحادي مقر سكنيه يحاذي مناطق
استراتيجيه فالتعامل في كل مطار ياخذ
وضعيه خاصه من حكم وجود المنطقه التي يوجد
فيها المطار هذا المطار مطار مروي الذي
يربط يعني الطريق السريع بين السودان ومصر
لديه نقاط استراتيجيه كما تحدثت نزار ان
كان بموضوع السدود التي تعتبر استراتيجيه
للسودانيين وايضا موضوع الربط بين القاره
الافريقيه والاوروبيه وغير عبر هذا المطار
اليوم السيطره عليهم من قبل يعني الجيش
الرسمي السوداني هل ممكن ان تؤثر بسير
المعارك الدائره باماكن اخرى
اذا ما ارتات القوات المسلحه السودانيه
بان تعيد استخدام هذا المطار وان يفعل من
جديد
ليستخدم كقاعده تنطلق منها اسرار الطيران
السوداني فيمكن ان يعبر الكف ويمكن ان
يحدث تاثيرات في مسار هذه العمليه اما اما
اذا كان على وضعيته الحاليه
فالي
اتيه هذا موضوع اخر وهذا حديث اخر
نزار يعني هل هناك اي تحديثات حول المناطق
الاخرى التي يدور فيها الصراع بهذه
الاثناء
في الولايه الشماليه يتركز فقط العمل
العسكري والاشتباكات داخل مطار مروي وداخل
القاعده الجويه ليس هنالك اي عمل عسكري
تقوم به القوات المسلحه السودانيه او يقوم
به الجيش السوداني او قوات الدعم السريع
في منطقه اخرى مغايره غير هذه المنطقه في
مناطق اخرى قد تكون في الخرطوم في شرق
النيل في ولايه الخرطوم في ام درمان في
مدينه الابيض في شرق السودان في بورسودان
في القضارف في دارفور على وجه الحدود في
وجه الخصوص هناك ايضا اشتباكات وعمليات
عسكريه في عدد من المناطق في دارفور على
سبيل المثال هنا تحضر مدينه الفاشر حاضره
ولايه شمال دارفور لكن في مروي خصوصيه هذه
المنطقه ان العمل العسكري فقط يتركز داخل
اطار محدد هو 18 كيلومتر مربع وهو حجب
ومساحه مطار مروي الدولي الذي الحقت به
القاعده العسكريه الجويه
نزار ابقى معنا لو سمحت مشاهدينا يعني
ايضا سنكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه المستمره
للاوضاع الامنيه في السود
ان التوتر لا يزال سيد الموقف في السودان
خيوط الخلافات بين مكونين عسكري ومدني
فتحت باب التساؤل حول الاسباب الاعمق لهذا
التوتر وتقود في نهايتها لمارس الماضي
وخلاف ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
الورشه التي اختتمت حينها وستغير بقاده
الجيش شهدت خلافات النشبت بين ضباط الجيش
المشاركين في ختام ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وقاده قوات الدعم السريع ابرز
نقاط الخلاف كان صياغه التوصيات الاخيره
للورشه التي تتطرق لاصلاحات امنيه ابرزها
مساله دمج قوات الدعم السريع مع الجيش
وتواريخ الدمج وتفاصيل الرتب حيث طالبت
ورقه الجيش بحصر دمج قوات الدعم السريع
خلال الفتره الانتقاليه التي حددها
الاتفاق الايطالي باربعه وعشرين شهرا ووضع
ترتيبات امنيه للحركات المسلحه الموقعه
على اتفاق جوبا للسلام السودان وفق جدا
محدده كما تحدد ورقه الجيش ضوابط ومعايير
قبول التحاق ضباط قوات الدعم السريع وتسرح
من تم تعيينهم بعد سقوط نظام الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير وتقنين صلاحيات الدعم
السريع العسكريه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه من
جهه اخرى الخلاف بين الدعم السريع والجيش
ليس خلافا فنيا حول فتره دمج قوات الدعم
السريع والتي تطالب الاخيره بان تكون خلال
عشر سنوات بل هو خلاف سياسي بسبب تقاطع
مواقف قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حميدتي
تجاه العمليه السياسيه والتحالفات
المستقبليه خاصه ان الدعم السريع نص
بتوصياته خلال ورشه الاصلاح الامني على
مراجعه وتطوير العقيده العسكريه وناي
المؤسسه العسكريه عن التدخل في السياسه
لكن الصراع بين الامبراطوريتين العسكريتين
اعمق من مجرد اختلاف على عمليه دمج القوات
فمصادر مقربه من البرهان ودجالو كشفت
بانهما مازال على خلاف حول من سيتقلد منصب
القائد العام للجيش خلال فتره الاندماج
التي ستمتد عده سنوات
شكرا لحضوركم
علق برنامج الاغذيه العالميه جميع
العمليات في السودان مؤقتا بعد مقتل ثلاثه
من موظفيه في شمال دارفور بالسودان خلال
الاشتباكات المسلحه التي تشهدها البلاد
وادانت الامم المتحده مقتل الموظفين
الثلاثه واوضحت انهم قتلوا انهم قتلوا
اثناء قيامهم بواجباتهم وعبر فولكر بيرتز
الممثل الخاص الامين العام للسودان عن
انزعاجه الشديد من اصابه منشات الامم
المتحده بمقذوفات بالاضافه الى تقارير عن
نهب مباني الامم المتحده وغيرها من
المباني الانسانيه في عده مواقع في دارفور
مشاهدينا للحديث اكثر عن تداعيات الاوضاع
الامنيه والسياسيه داخل السودان ينضم
الينا من القاهره عطيه العيساوي الباحث
المتخصص في الشؤون الافريقيه بمركز
الاهرام استاذ عطيه سابدا من السيطره على
مطار مروي طبعا يعني سننتقل بعد الى
الخلافات العميقه الموجوده اليوم بين
الطرفين ولكن باخر التحديثات السيطره
الكامله للجيش السوداني على مطار مروي
بعدما استولت عليه قوات الدعم السريع
بالساعات الماضيه هذه السيطره لمطار يعتبر
استراتيجي
يربطين بين مصر والسودان ما معناه
نعم هو هي خطوه جيده لصالح القوات المسلحه
سترفع معنويات القوات افراد القوات
المسلحه في مناطق الصراع الاخرى مثل
المنطقه المحيطه
بقياده الجيش في الخرطوم وايضا مطار
الخرطوم واماكن اخرى ما زالت ما زالت قوات
او افراد الدعم السريع ما زالوا يسيطرون
عليها او على الاقل
يطوقونها ويقاتلون فيها هذا طبعا مؤشر جيد
لكن
التحفظ هنا في اعتقادي انه يمكن للقوات او
للافراد الذين خرجوا باربعين سياره
من سيارات الدعم السريع من قاعده مروى ومن
المطار يمكن ان يكون لدي خطه للعوده
للالتفاف على القاعده او على المطار مره
اخرى او يكونوا قد قرروا الذهاب لتعزيز
اوضاع زملائهم في منطقه اخرى وبالتالي لا
اظن ان القتال
سينتهي بسرعه
لان كل طرف يحاول ان يعزز مواقفه ويسيطر
على اكبر قدر او عدد من المواقع
تحسبا لان يتم الضغط عليهما
لوقف اطلاق النار والدخول في مفاوضات
سيحاول كل طرف ان يعزز مواقفه الميدانيه
حتى
يتفاوض منه
الحوار نعم قوات الدعم السريع من المعلوم
يعني تاريخها الطويل مع بقتال المتمردين
والمليشيات وغيره على الارض وكيف تشكلت
وكل تاريخها وبالتالي لديها خبره كبيره
بطريقه اداره المعارك على الارض من هنا
يعني يصعب الحديث او من الصعب التكهم بان
هزيمتها ستكون سريعه ماذا يعني ذلك بسير
المعارك الموجوده اليوم على الارض
معك حق تماما في هذا
عدد وعديد قوات الدعم السريع الذي يصل الى
ما بين سبعين الفا الى مئه الف
يشير ويؤكد بل في اعتقادي يؤكد انه ان
المعارك لن تتم او تنتهي بسرعه
وحتى ولو خسرت ذلك وعلى افتراض ان الدعم
السريع هزموا في الخرطوم وام درمان وغيرها
من المناطق ومروي وغيرها من المناطق اعتقد
انهم ان لم يتم الاتفاق على حل
الدمج افراد الدعم السريع في قوات الجيش
حل مرضي للطرفين اعتقد انهم يمكن ان
ينسحبوا
ويفر الى دارفور ويشكلوا قوه تمرد كبيره
هناك تعيد الاوضاع في دارفور الى حالتها
او احوالها السيئه جدا
ومقاسيها التي حدثت بعد
انطلاق تمرد دارفور في العام 2003
نعم لديهم خبره كبيره كبيره ويعرفون
التضاريس الارض جيدا
ويحتمون بابناء القبائل التي ينتمون اليها
ولديهم خطوط امدادهم ستكون اكثر كثيرا
في دارفور اذا تجمعوا في دارفور
غير خطوط الامداد الطويله حاليا التي يمكن
قطعها بسهوله من الجيش لكن
المساله لن تكون سهله
والقتال القتال على الارض يحتاج الى افراد
والافراد متوفرون في الدعم السريع وفي
قوات الجيش لان الطيران مثلا طيران الحربي
لا يمكن ان
يتولى كل شيء او يقوم بقصف
اماكنون صحيح المناطق متداخله مع مدنيين
وبالتالي الحسم هو حسم على الارض
وليس هناك يعني من كافه قوه ترجح انتصار
طرف على طرف اخر حتى وان كنا نتحدث عن
اختلاف بالعديد والعتاد بين الطرفين ولكن
طبعا يعني هناك نقاط قوه لكل طرف على
الاخر استاذ عطيه اليوم هذا الصراع هو
نتيجه صراع مباشر بين يعني اطراف السلطه
او على السلطه بين اطراف القياده العسكريه
ولكن قبل ان اخذ الجواب
فلنستمع الى
الاشتباكات الصوت الطبيعي للاشتباكات التي
عادت لتشتد واعود اليك استاذ عطيه ابقى
معي لو سمحت
اذا الاشتباكات عادت
اذا مشاهدينا عاده الاشتباكات لتشتد في
المناطق التي كانت اصلا دائره فيها طيله
ساعات الصراع بساعات الماضيه مع دخول
الليل ومع حلول الليل هناك في السودان
الاشتباكات تشتد اكثر كما نلاحظ يعني
النيران تشتعل
وايضا
اصوات اطلاق الرصاص واطلاق النيران
الكثيفه التي
يرصدن او يوافينا بها الزملاء من هناك
اعود اليك استاذ عطيه كنت اقول لك بان
يعني ما يحدث اليوم من صراع على الارض هو
نتيجه مباشره لصراع على السلطه بين افراد
القياده العسكريه يعني هذا هو العنوان
العريض والباقي كله تفاصيل هذا العنوان ما
الذي ممكن ان يؤججوا بالفتره المقبله
لنتحدث عن صراع طويل وما الذي يمكن ان
يسهل او يعني يفتح طريق للحلحله والحوار
بين الطرفين
يعني اعتقد ان المعارك قد لا تنتهي في وقت
قصير
وان قوات الدعم السريع ستحاول بكل
امكانياتها ان تصمت في بعض الاماكن
لحتى لا تخسر
تخسر تخسر كل الاماكن وتدخل
المفاوضات اذا اذا قدر للمفاوضات ان تبدا
من مركز ضعف
اعتقد ان الامر
ربما يؤدي اذا لم يتم الاتفاق كما قلت
يؤدي الى انسحابهم للتمرد في دارفور او
اماكن اخرى
اعتقد ان
الازمه يجب ان ياخذ انسحاب الى دارفور او
مناطق اخرى طبعا يعني مازال من الممكن
الحديث عنها بما انها ليس هناك يعني اي
تطور ممكن ان يحسم الصراع الاطار لصالح
طرف على حساب طرف اخر ولكن هل هذا يعني
انسحاب الى هذه المنطقه تعقيد العمليه
السياسيه من جديد خصوصا بان يعني الاهتزاز
الامني داخل السودان هو الملف الاساسي
الذي اخر كل العمليه العمليه الانتقاليه
بالمرحله الماضيه
يعني فيما يتعلق
باتفاق سلام جوبا اعتقد انه مهدد اذا لم
يتم التوصل الى اتفاق لحل الازمه بين
الشقين المكون العسكري
ربما يدفع ذلك القاده القاده حركات
المسلحه المتمرده الذين وقعوا على اتفاق
سلام جوبا
للانسحاب منه او تجميده والعوده لاستئناف
التمرد في اقاليمهم
مدعين ان الاوضاع في الخرطوم لا تبشر بخير
وايا وايا كانت الحكومه من وجهه نظرهم
فلن يحصلوا على حقوقهم
المتمثله في اقتسام السلطه والثروه
والتنميه الغائبه في تلك الاماكن من وجهه
نظرهم اما على مستوى
الاتفاق
الاقتسام السلطه ما بين المدنيين
والعسكريين او عوده حكومه المدنيه اعتقد
ان البرهان سوف ينفذ هذا الاتفاق لو
سيطره على الاوضاع وكانت اصبحت له اليد
العليا في
السلطه سينفذ هذا الاتفاق ويسمح لحكومه
مدنيه
التشكيل واداره شؤون البلاد اولا لاستعاده
الثقه التي فقدها لدى كثير من
المدنيين بسبب هذه الحرب مع قوات الدعم
السريع وايضا
[موسيقى]
القاء المسؤوليه على المجتمع المدني للاسف
بعد ان يكون قد تم تدمير الكثير من
المخدرات السودان سوف يلقي بالمسؤوليه لدى
لكي يدير
الصعوبه المس ؤوليه
المدنيين على من اطراف المدنيه ساعود
واتحدث عنها بعد قليل ابقى معنا استاذ
عطيه العيساوي الباحث المتخصص من القاهره
مشاهدينا هذه صور تظهر مبنى القياده
العامه للقوات البريه السودانيه في
العاصمه الخرطوم قبل وبعد استهدافه جراء
الاشتباك وتظهر طبعا الصور حجم الدمار
والحرائق التي لحقت بالمبنى اذا صور
للمبنى مبنى القياده العامه للقوات البريه
السودانيه قبل وبعد الاشتباكات تتحدث يعني
عن يومين اشتباك ليس اكثر وهذه اولى
الاضرار التي تم رفض دمار هائل لحق بهذا
المبنى
وهذه ايضا مشاهدينا صور خاصه للعربيه من
اشتباكات الخرطوم اذا سنستعرض واياكم هذه
الصور الخاصه لقناه العربيه من اشتباكات
الخرطوم التي بدات نهار السبت بعد يعني
اشتعال فتيل هذه المواجهه حينما تحركت
قوات الدعم السريع نحو مدينه مروي ونحو
طبعا المطار هناك الاشتباكات ما زالت
دائره حتى هذه الساعه وهي تشتد بساعات
وتخف بساعات اخرى مجددا صور خاصه لقناه
العربيه من اشتباكات الخرطوم
فنشاهدها ونتابعها معكم مشاهدينا
قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها انها سيطرت
على القصر الجمهوري فلنتابع
العربيه
الله اكبر
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه في برج القوات
البريه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وايضا فيديو متداول الاستمرار الاشتباكات
في محيط سلاح الاشاره وقربه منزل دقلو في
احدى المناطق السودانيه
البي
وت دي حضري متبهدل من هنا
مربع سته
اما الدخان ده طبعا
[موسيقى]
حريقه كبيره شديد
اتجاه المطار والغياب العامه
تحديدا يعني
هذا ونشر مشاهدينا الجيش السوداني مقطع
فيديو مصورا لعمليه فراره عناصر من قوات
الدعم السريع فلنتابعها كما نشاهد بهذه
الصور
اذا وهذه الصور حصريه لقناه العربيه
للاشتباكات الدائره اليوم في الخرطوم بين
عناصر من الدعم السريع طبعا والجيش
السوداني
نعود مشاهدينا الى ضيف من القاهره اعطينا
العيساوي الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه استاذ عيسى كنا نتحدث عن
مسؤوليه المجتمع المدني في حال يعني انتهت
هذه المعركه لصالح البرهان سيذهب لتحميل
هذه القهوه مسؤوليه من الناحيه السياسيه
ومن الناحيه يعني كل المشهد السياسي داخل
السودان ولكن هناك ايضا الكثير من
التحليلات عن ان عمليه الحوار بين الطرفين
صعبه جدا نحن نتحدث عن مكاسب سياسيه
وعسكريه وامنيه يريد الطرفين الحفاظ عليها
اذا في حال بقيت الصوره كما هي هناك
العديد من التحليلات التي تطالب الشعب
والمجتمع السوداني بالتدخل لايقاف حمام
الدم ويعني وضع حد
لطرفي النزاع هل بقدره اي من المكونات
المدنيه او اي من الموجودين اليوم من
الشعب السوداني القيام بهذا
بالتاكيد الشعب السوداني شعب سياسي بطبعه
ولديه القيادات حزبيه قويه
يمكن ان تتدخل ولديه شخصيه قويه
مثل عبد الله حمدوك رئيس الوزراء السابق
الذي كان اول من تنبا
باحتمال انزلاق الطرفين الى العسكريين الى
حرب وناشدها المجتمع الدولي وكل الاطراف
في الداخل والخارج الاسراع بالعمل على
احتواء الموقف
لديهم الكثير من الكفاءات لكن اعتقد ان
الطرفين العسكريين لن يستجيب بسهوله لذلك
لماذا لان كل طرف يريد ان يقضي على الطرف
الاخر او على الاقل يسخنه بالجراح لكي
يتفاوض معه
من منطق قوه من منطلق قوه ويحصل على اكبر
قدر من المزايا
والمناصب القياديه
واعتقد ان انه لن يستجيب احد منهما اقصد
رئيس
قائد الجيش او قائد الدعم السريع
لوقف اطلاق النار
والمفاوضات الا اذا شعر بان
التطورات الميدانيه ليست في صالحه
وبالتالي يمكن ان يوافق على ذلك اما لرغبه
حقيقيه في حل المشكله عن طريق التفاوض
واما لاعاده تنظيم الصفوف والبدء جوله
جديده من
الاشتباكات والحرب هنا المجتمع السوداني
المدني
يلام في
في انه هو كان سببا في ان القاده الجيش
استولوا على السلطه بسبب خلافاتهم
وانقساماتهم انقسامات المجتمع المدني
والاحزاب
وايضا رجال رجل الشارع
ادى ذلك الى ان
القياده العسكريه رات انه ليس هناك من
تفاوضه او تتفاوض معه لاقتصام السلطه
والبدء في تنفيذ الفتره الانتقاليه ولذلك
قام بالانقلاب على حكومه حمدوق واستولى
على السلطه
وطالما ان
الامور كانت تسير في صالح الطرفين قياده
الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع فكانت الخلافات
مكتومه على الاقل او كانت هناك يعني عمليه
توافق لكن عندما
تم الاتفاق على تسليم السلطه
للقياده او لحكومه مدنيه بالكامل
وانسحاب القوات المسلحه للتفرغ لما اهمها
الاساسيه الدستوريه في حمايه حدود البلاد
حدثت الخلافات وبدا كل يحشد
افراده وقواته لمواجهه الطرف الاخر خصوصا
يعني انكم من ح
والي كنا نسمع تقارير واخبار عن حشد قوات
ان كان للدعم السريع او للجيش من المناطق
الاخرى الى داخل الخرطوم وبالتالي كان
هناك تحضر لهذه اللحظه وتحضير لها وليست
هي يعني لحظه وليده قرار باخر دقيقه
بالتالي خلافات عميقه سنتحدث عنها ونفصلها
مجددا استاذ ابقى معنا لو سمحت
سنتابع بعض المواد المتعلقه بهذه المواجهه
واعود اليك
الله اكبر الله اكبر ده كله مال العدو
كلهم البرهان برهان
رويال برهان
[موسيقى]
الزلم دباباتك
تمثل مشاهدينا قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان التي تضم نحو 100 الف عنصر اهميه
عسكريه وامنيه عملت خلال تاسيسها مع وحدات
واجهزه مهمه ابرز هذه المهمات جهاز الامن
والمخابرات ورئاسه الجمهوريه فلنتابع قوات
الدعم السريع
انبثقت من قوات الجنجويد في 2003 اعتمد
عليها البشير في هزيمه المتمردين في
دارفور
تاسست في عام 2013
عملت تحت وحده استخبارات حرس الحدود بعدها
تبعت قياده جهاز الامن والمخابرات
في 2016 اصبحت تابعه لرئاسه الجمهوريه وفي
البرلمان يقر تاسيس قوات الدعم السريع تحت
قياده الرئيس رغم تبعيتها للجيش من
اهدافها دعم ومعاونه الجيش والقوات
النظاميه التصدي لحالات الطوارئ المحدده
قانونا تضم نحو 100 الف مقاتل لها مراكز
في دارفور وشمال وغرب كردفان لها وجود
كبير بولايه البحر الاحمر ومواقع قرب
حلايب اسست مقر عديده في العاصمه الخرطوم
للحديث اكثر عن المعارك الدائره الان في
الخرطوم معنا مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
سالم يعني اخر التطورات هناك خصوصا اننا
شاهدنا قبل دقائق احتدام المواجهات من
جديد بين قوات دعم السريع والجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
الجيش لكن لم تنفذ هذه الهدنه للاسف
والاندلعت المواجهه اشد شراسه في ساعات
الماضيه او في الساعه الماضيه بالتحديد
شهدت نزاع كبيرا في الخرطوم وفي ام درمان
وتبادل الكثير في اطلاق النار هذا
بالاضافه الى القنابل واستخدام المدافع
الثقيله ايضا ننوه الى انه بدات بالفعل
تعود
التيار الكهرباء تدريجيا الى انحاء من
العاصمه الخرطوم رجوعه الكهربائي بالتدريج
هذه في في الساعتين والثلاث ساعات الماضيه
بدا يعود التيار الكهربائيه كذلك المياه
ضمنها تعود تدريجيا في بالنسبه لانحاء
العاصمه الخرطوم ككل في هذه الساعه
الماضيه
سالم يعني
بموازاه ذلك كان هناك عمليه احتجاز ان كان
لصحفيين ان كان يعني للسكان هل الساعات
التي تم الاتفاق فيها على الهدنه كانت
كفيله باخراج عدد كبير من المحتجزين ومن
الناس الذين علقوا نتيجه هذا الصراع
للاسف ان هذه الهدنه حينما طلبت بالامس
وتم رفع نداءها كانت الحالتين من الاكثر
حوجه او حاجه لهذه الهدنه هم الحاله
الاولى مدارس بالنسبه للتلاميذ الموجودون
في مدارس كومبو وايضا
لمستشفى غسيل الكلى الذي ليس بعيد من هذه
المنطقه مع اعلان هذه الهدنه
المنطقه التي فيها غسيل الكلى وفيها مدرس
كومبلي هي اكثر منطقه شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه
في ساعات الهدنه لكن الان وانا اتحدث معك
يعني يعم هدوء نسبي توقف لاطلاق الناريه
في هذه اللحظات توقف لتبادل اطلاق النار
لا نسمع الان اي دليل انفجارات او او اي
صواريخ او اي نوع من انواع الاسلحه في هذه
اللحظات التي اتحدث فيها فيها
على الاقل في المدينتين اللتين بقربي
الخرطوم وبحري سالم ما هو الوضع الامني
لمطار الخرطوم الذي يعتبر يعني نقطه
الان هناك اراده كما تسمعين الان نسمع هذه
الاعياد نعم هذه الاعيره الناريه في محيط
القصر الرئاسي في هذه اللحظات
بالنسبه لمطار الخرطوم مطار الخرطوم
في جهات من مطار الخرطوم خارجيته تسيطر
عليها قوات الدعم السريع الجهه الشرقيه
لمطار الخرطوم الجهه الجنوبيه لمطار
الخرطوم كذلك الجهه الغربيه لمطار الخرطوم
كانه طوق مكتمل تنقصه الجهه الرابعه وهي
الجهه الشماليه الجهه الشماليه لمطار
الخرطوم والتي تقع فيها القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه والقياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه تشكل تفوق نستطيع ان نقول من جهه
شرقيه الى شرقيه شماليه في مطار الخرطوم
هذه الجهه هي محل النزاع الان بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
ايضا يعني بالصوره الاخرى هناك معارك بعده
مناطق دائره هل حسمت اي معركه لصالح طرف
على طرف اخر
لم تتاكد بعد اي واحده من المعارك حسب لاي
طرف من الاطراف حتى هذه اللحظه سوى ما
اعلنه الجيش السوداني عن استيلائه على
مقارن الدعم السريع في ولايات مختلفه وعند
هذه الولايات وايضا هنا نستثمر ايضا قاعده
كرري التي سيطرت عليها القوات المسلحه بعد
قصف كثيف لها بالطائرات كان بالامس وفجر
اليوم اعلن الجيش السوداني سيطرته الكامله
على معسكر الذي كان يتبع الدعم السريع
وهذا المعسكر كان في ام درمان واخليه
تماما من قوات الدعم السريع او الميليشيا
المتمرده كما يقول الجيش السوداني
سالم هل تم استقدام مزيد من القوات من
خارج الخرطوم الى الخرطوم خصوصا ان يعني
بالبدايه او ما قبل بدا الصراع على الارض
تم استقدام قوات لان كان هناك علم لدى
الطرفين بانهم ذاهبين الى مواجهه
نعم لكن في هذه الاثناء هذه المواجهه لم
يعلن
او دعمه قوات له بشكل او باخر او توافد اي
قوات من خارج المنطقه التي هو فيها حتى
هذه اللحظات يعني لم يعلن اي طرف هذه
الاطراف عن استقلابه او استدعائه لقوات من
خارج الخرطوم منذ اندلاع هذه
الامدادات
ساتحدث يعني عن الشاقه الانساني للناس
للمواطنين خصوصا اننا الان يعني في شهر
رمضان وهناك حتى بالحالات الطبيعيه هناك
حاجات لامدادات غذائيه وطبيه وغيرها هل
يعني هناك وضع كارثه بهذا الشان اما ان
طرفي النزاع يعني بالساعات الماضيه تمرير
البعض منها
لم يتم تمريض اي شيء يظهر انه لم تكن في
غزلان الطرفين ان تستمر المواجهات لايام
او ان تاخذ حي الزمان كثير يظهر هذا من
عدم ترتيب هذه النقطه نقطه
الامر الانساني وتمرير المواد الغذائيه او
وضع زمن بهدنا يمكن للمواطنين ان يتحركوا
فيها لياخذوا احتياجاتهم المواطنون الان
يعانون فعلا من الوصول وصول المواده
الغذائيه لهم في منازلهم ايضا اغلاق المحل
التجاريه اغلاق الاسواق كل هذه امور ونحن
في اواخر شهر رمضان وبدايه
عيد الفطر السعيد كل هذه الاحداث غريبه
بالفعل وجديده على المواطن السوداني او
ربما يعني هناك من المتشائمين من يصفون
بانها تجديد لما حدثت في فض الاعتصام
القياده العامه في عام 2019 حينما كان في
نهايه شهر رمضان كذلك
يعني كنت ذكرت قبل قليل عوده الهدوء الى
تدريجيا الى العاصمه الخرطوم هل ممكن يعني
ان نعيد هذه المعلومه وننقل الصوره لو
سمحت
نعم هي عاده تدريجيا لكن قبل ان اكمل
الحديث يستمعنا الى صوت اصوات للرصاص
وطلقات في محيط القياده العامه لكن هو
الهدوء الان هدوء نسبي نستطيع ان نقول
ودائما مثل هذه المواجهات بعد هذا الهدوء
عاده يكون هناك هجوم شرس بعد هذه الهدنه
او بعد هذه الراحه ان صحه العباره سالم
يعني بالتحليلات التي سمعناها من بعض
الضيوف بان
الانسحاب من قاعده مروي ممكن ان يعني كما
تحدثت ان تكون تاسس لهجوم ودعم بمناطق
اخرى اي نادي يتركز الصراع اليوم باي نقاط
بالعاصمه الخرطوم وما هي النقاط
استراتيجيه التي يدور
الصراع حوله
ابرز النقاط التي يدور الصراع حولها في
هذا اليوم القصر الجمهوري كذلك القياده
العامه للجيش مطار الخرطوم كذلك
ايضا
سلاح المهندسين في ام درمان ايضا يعني
هناك مناطق اخرى شهدت الشباك عنيف كذلك في
منطقه
كوبر من قرب من سجن كوبر السجن الذي يقطن
فيه الرئيس السابق عمر البشير الذي هو
مسجون الان كوبر هناك
شهد اشتباكات عنيفه جدا في هذه المنطقه
لان هذه المنطقه تحتوي على واحده من وحدات
الجيش السوداني
يعني بتوزيع هذه المعارك اي او يعني كنت
ذكرت قبل قليل بانه ليس هناك اي عمليات
حسم ولا منطقه وبالتالي هل يعني بالساعات
المقبله ستشتد المعارك بهذه النقاط او
ممكن ان تتوسع على نقاط اخرى
ايوه طبعا حتى تتضح الصوره للمشاهد
اليوم يعني كان بالامس هناك حسم بالنسبه
للجيش السوداني في مناطق مختلفه في ام
درمان وكان من تركيزه بالامس على مدينه ام
درمان وبالفعل نجح في تحقيق
يعني تحقيق معسكر كرري بان يكون خالي من
المتفلثين المتمردين كما ذكر الجيش
السوداني ولكن اليوم لم نشهد اي واحده من
مثل هذه التي حدثت لمعسكر ان تكون هناك
ضرب مثلا متواصل في منطقه معينه ثم يعني
الجيش السوداني سيطرته الكامله على هذه
المنطقه ومن ثم تنتشر كل الصور
والفيديوهات وتثبت انه فعلا ان هذه
المنطقه اصبحت خاليه من القوات الدعم
السريعه والعكس كذلك ان تكون قوات الدعوه
السريع مثلا بمثل هذا الامر لكن اليوم لم
يحدث اي من هذه الامور كحسم مطلق كامل
لمنطقه من المناطق المتنازع حتى الان ابقى
معنا لو سمحت سالم وايضا ضيفنا من القاهره
مشاهدينا ساكمل هذه التغطيه حيث اعلنت
اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء في
السودان عن مقتل خمسه مدنيين واصابه 78 في
الاشتباكات الدائره اليوم بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع في البلاد وقالت النقابه في
بيان على صفحتها بفيسبوك انه توجد اصابات
ووفيات لم يتم حصرها بسبب عدم تمكن
الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول لبعض المستشفيات
لصعوبه التنقل وبسبب الوضع الامني في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعود مشاهدينا الى القاهره وضيف عطيه
العيساوي الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه استاذ عطيه يعني
سانتقل الى نقطه وهي الموضوع المصري
والدوري المصري بهذا الصراع من المعروف
بان الملف السوداني هو ملف امن قومي
بالنسبه لمصر بسبب يعني تداخل ان كان
التداخل الجغرافي او الملفات الاخرى بين
الطرفين اليوم يعني المبادره التي ممكن ان
تطلقها ان كان القاهره او الدول العربيه
او المجتمع الدولي التي ممكن ان تجد حل
بين الطرفين خصوصا وان هناك تعنت من قبل
طرفي النزاع والصراع على السلطه وعلى يعني
المكاسب الامنيه والعسكريه التي ممكن ان
يحققوها بختام هذه المعارك
يعني
اعتقد ان مصر
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
واكثر من دوله
مهتمه جدا
بوقف اطلاق النار بسرعه والشروع في
مفاوضات لحل المشكله لكن
المخاوف تنحصر في رايي في ان
اللهجه اللهجه الحاده التي
استخدمها كل طرف قائد
الجيش السوداني
بوصفه بحل الميليشيا وصفهم بالمتمردين
وبرفض التفاوض معهم قبل ان
يتم
استسلامهم وايضا وصف قائد الدعم السريع
للقائد الجيش بانه مجرم كل هذه
الاوصاف والتصريحات تدل على ان
مضادات ان بدات ستكون صعبه جدا
ومع ذلك لن تدخر مصر ولا اي دوله عربيه
بامكانها المساعده ولا حتى دوله اجنبيه
جهدا
لتحقيق هذا الهدف وهو وقف سفك الدماء اولا
ثم الشروع في مفاوضات
لكن في ظني ايضا انه اذا كما قلت من قبل
انه لن يخضع اي من الطرفين
للتفاوض او لم يقبل بالتفاوض الا اذا حس
انه سيخسر الوضع على الارض وبالتالي يمكن
ان يقبل
باقل ما يمكن او باحسن ما يمكن تحقيقه من
خلال المفاوضات ايضا لطرف
المنتصر اليوم يخدم المكون العسكري الذي
هو يعني طيله الفتره الماضيه يعني ليس ليس
هناك مكون عسكري يكون راغب بتسليم القوى
المدنيه عاده مقاليد السلطه ولكن اليوم
الصراع الدائر بين الطرفين في حال انتهى
الى حاله يعني جامد لا غلبه لطرف على طرف
اخر كيف يمكن ان يعزز الطرفان وجودهم وجود
داخل السلطه وكيف ان ينعكس ذلك على مسار
عمليه السلام والانتقال انتقال السلطه الى
المكون المدني
يعني اولا استمرار هذه
المعارك والتوتر
القائم سيؤخر بالتاكيد عمليه انتقال
السلطه الى حكومه مدنيه لانه لا يمكن
استلام السلطه من قبل المدنيين في ظل هذه
الاجواء
وعمليات القتال والدمار وغيرها وللاسف
الشديد حسب اخر
خبرين قراتهما على شاشه العربيه منذ لحظات
هو ان الدعم السريع تحوله او يتحولون الى
فرق صغيره للقتال من داخل خنادق فيما يبدو
حتى يتفادوا البشريه اذا تجمعوا في منطقه
معينه
عفوا وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن حرب شوارع
وحرب الشوارع عاده ما يكون اماذا اطول
بكثير من الحرب يعني المنظمه باماكن محدده
والامر الاخر لو سمحتي لي هو ما ورد ايضا
على شاشه العربيه من ان مصادر عسكريه
سودانيه توقعت ان يستمر القتال لمده اسبوع
على الاقل وهذا يدل على ان المساله لم
تنتهي بعد ولم يتم احتواء الدعم السريع
بعد رغم تحقيق بعض الانتصارات من قبل
الجيش في بعض المناطق والدليل على ذلك
المعارك الدائره حول القصر الجمهوري وحول
مطار الخرطوم وحول القياده العسكريه التي
من المفروض ان تكون اكثر
المناطق والاماكن امانا
وبعيدا عن مثل هذه
المعارك خاصه ان الدعم السريع لا يملك
طائرات نقول ان مثلا الطائرات ستقصف عن
بعد لكن ان يصلوا الى المنطقه وان يحاصروا
مبنى القياده العسكريه فهذا يدل على ان
الموقف ليس سهلا ابدا وان المساله ستطول
فيما يتعلق
لن يكون حاسم بهذه المعركه بسبب الخوف من
الخسائر البشريه المدنيه اتحدث هنا استاذ
ابقى معي لو سمحت سنكمل تحديث ونقل
الاخبار والتغطيه لهذا الصراع حيث اسفلت
الاحداث مشاهدينا طبعا الاحداث العسكريه
في السودان تعليق الرحلات من والى السودان
من مطارات المملكه العربيه السعوديه ماده
للتعلق عشرات من المواطنين السودانيين في
مطار الملك عبد العزيز في جده غربيه
السعوديه هذا وكانت عده شركات طيران
تجاريه اعلنت عن توقف رحلتها الى السودان
بعد تعرض طائرات مدنيه للخراب بعد الهجوم
المسلح الذي نفذ عليها اليوم
هذا وقد طلبت جامعه الدول العربيه
المتحاربين في السودان بوقف النار فورا
حقنا لدماء المدنيين ومقدرات الشعب
السوداني ووحده اراضيه وسيادته كما حث
بيانا الاجتماع الذي دعت اليه كل من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومصر حتى طرفي
النزاع الى العوده السريعه الى المسار
السلمي لحل الازمه السودانيه وحذرت جامعه
الدول العربيه من خطوره تداعيات التصعيد
في السودان على المستويين الداخلي والاقلي
هذا واكد البيان على استعداد جامعه الدول
العربيه لبذل كافه المساعي من اجل معاونه
السودان على انهاء الازمه الراهنه بما وفق
مصالح السودانيين واعرضت جامعه الدول
العربيه عن اساسها الشديد لسقوط ضحايا
خلال الاشتباكات الاخيره في السودان
اعود الى الاستاذ عطيه العيساوي من
القاهره الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه بمركز الاهرام استاذ يعني هذه
الجهود العربيه كنا تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل
ولكن ساتطرق لنقطه قبل ان ننهي هذه
التغطيه وننتقل للساعه الاخرى هل يمكن
اتحدث هنا عن قوات الدعم السريع التي
تعتبر يعني قد اشتهرت منذ بدايتها بمواجهه
وملاحقه حركات التمرد والنهب وبالتالي
لديها خبره كبيره بحرب الشوارع على الارض
هل خبرته اكبر بهذا الموضوع من خبره الجيش
السوداني
السؤال لي نعم
الخط قطع
هل
اذا
قد انقطع الاتصال مع استاذ عطيه مشاهدينا
كما نتابع بهذه الصور لعمليات المواجهه
التي ما زالت مستمره ودائره وقد اشتدت
بساعات الماضيه بين كل من قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني انها النزاع
المسلح المتواصل بين الجيش السوداني
بقياده عبد الفتاح البرهان وقوات الدعم
السريع بقياده محمد دقلو علاقه تعاون
وتحالف قديمه بين الرجلين امتدت لاكثر من
عقدين من الزمن فكيف تطورت هذه العلاقه
قبل ان تنقلب الى عداوه كامله ادت الى
مواجهه بين الطرفين فانتابع
السودان يسقط في وحل الاقتتال بين اقوى
الرجلين عسكريين في البلاد فانقطاع حبل
الود بين عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدانو
اوقع السودان في المحظور اتهامات وتوعد
وتهديد بالقتل هكذا تحول الخطاب بين
الرجلين الذين نسفا في لحظات علاقه تحالف
وعمل مشترك دامت نحو 20 عاما الرجلان عمل
سويا لاول مره سنه 2003 حين اتحدا للتصدي
لجماعات المسلحه في اقليم دارفور الملقب
بحميتي انشا حينها مجموعه صغيره مسلحه
ووضع يده في يد البرهان الذي كان حينها
منسقا لعمليات الجيش في دارفور ومنذ ذلك
الحين والرجلان يصعدان المراتب بشكل
تدريجي عاد ليتصدر المشهد سنه 2019 حين
اتحدا من جديد وهذه المره ليس الا لاسقاط
عمر البشير الذي قاتلا تحت رايته سويا قبل
سته عشر عاما
هدف مشترك جمعهما ليبرما تحالفا
استراتيجيا لكن انهاء مهام الحكومه
المدنيه وسيطره البرهان الى جانب حميتي
على الحكم خليفه سنه 2021 حمل معه اولى
شذرات الخلاف الحقيقيه فالبرهان اعاد بعد
عناصر نظام البشير الى السلطه وهو ما
اعترض عليه حميتي لكن نقطه التي افادت
الكاس تمخضت عن الاتفاق الاطاري الذي حمل
بين ثناياه مقترح اصلاح النظام العسكري
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع مقترح كان مجرد
قنبله موقوته انفجرت لتنهي تحالفا
استراتيجيا وتشعل عداوه قد تحرق نيرانها
البلاد وسام الذهبي العربيه
مشاهدينا تغطيه العربيه مستمره على مدار
الساعه لرص اخر تطورات المشهد في السودان
منذ بدا المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع سنواصل هذه التغطيه مع
الزميله رينبوغامرا بعد قليل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات